I'm sorry Android folks but you've got
to admit that the iPhone 15 Pro Max
destroys Android now yes not everything
is better but as an overall package this
is the better phone and in this video
I'm going to give you guys 15 reasons
why the 15 Pro Max destroys anything
that Android has to offer getting into
reason number one we have the brand new
USBC Port which of course you're going
to say Android has had for literally
years on end but the iPhone 15 Pro Max
actually does it better this USBC Port
supports transfer speeds of up to 10
gbits per second while even the best
Android flagships like I would say
arguably the s23 ultra is the best on
the Android side that only supports up
to 5 gbits per second transfer speeds
now in the real world people have done
real transfer tests and they found that
the iPhone is actually three times
faster than the comparable s23 Ultra in
a real test so Apple did wait so many
years before implementing USBC thanks to
the EU but when they finally did it they
did it better than everybody else now
getting into reason number two we have
the main camera which of course the
sensor has not changed from the previous
14 pro Max but what Apple did across the
board for the iPhone 15 lineup is that
they've defaulted the photo output to 24
megapixels double the resolution
compared to how it's been for many years
and what you get on any other Android
phone so clearly when you take a closer
look at regular 1X camera photos Apple's
iPhone 15 Pro Max is on top and yes it
even works automatically for portrait
photos and live photos because of
Apple's killer optimization and the new
chip for reason number three we have the
speakers being the best out of any
smartphone ever beating a lot of actual
laptops and tablets these speakers are
absolutely insane just listen to how
they compare to the s23
[Music]
ultra
now for number four we have the bezels
and these are the thinnest uniform
bezels on any smartphone ever these look
absolutely insane better than the s23
ultra and we actually have rumors of the
s24 ultra having uniform bezels but
they're actually slightly bigger than
they were before on the sides of the s23
ultra so these are definitely the best
for number five let's get into that new
5x Tetra prism lens and the really
unique thing about this is that Apple's
actually allowing 5x portrait shots
which look absolutely incredible almost
looking like real dslrs because of that
focal length and all the compression in
the back it looks absolutely insane
while Samsung can only do it with the 3x
lens you can't do portraits with the s23
ultra 10x lens
which is one of the reasons why they're
actually getting rid of the 10x and
going back to 5x following an Apple's
footsteps and yes the pixel 7 Pro also
cannot do portraits in 3 or 5x it
actually crops from the 1X lens so those
portraits look terrible now on to number
six we have Max safe which has been in
the iPhone since iPhone 12 and now there
are so many different accessories that
you can plop right on the back of the
naked iPhone so many Chargers 15w Car
mounts with cooling like the one from
ESR my favorite Mac safe wallet from
mofft which I love right on the back of
the iPhone now yes Androids are getting
ch2 which is literally Apple's Mac safe
built into Androids but we haven't seen
any of those yet and for now Android
phones are literally just using Mac safe
cases to support all these accessories
because this feature is so good and
speaking of the massive ecosystem of Max
saafe accessories for the iPhone we have
the new ring LAX case from our sponsor
JX it comes with a really nice design
and either black blue beige or pink
colors but the standout feature is the
ring that comes with the most
flexibility I have ever seen being able
to rotate around
360° which means it's fully Max safe
charging compatible unlike other Ring
cases but the ring is also on a hinge so
you can easily twist and use it as a
stand in both orientations even better
the ring itself has a hinge so you can
comfortably use it as a finger grip so
you don't drop your phone or if your
hands are full and you can hang it off
of one finger like this or even hang it
off of a hook or a lanyard they also
have a bunch of new USB accessories for
the iPhone 15 like their long braided
cable usba a and headphone jack adapters
USBC Hub and data blockers and you can
order these including the ring LAX Case
by using the links in the description
below and now let's get back to the
seventh reason why the iPhone 15 Pro Max
destroys Android one of them is the new
A7 Pro chip with the CPU performance
that is way ahead of any Android smart
smart phone and even the new leaks that
are showing up for the upcoming
Snapdragon 8 gen 3 that is still not
coming anywhere close to the performance
of the A7 Pro we also just had leaks for
the new Google tensor G3 chip that thing
is insanely slow still so far behind the
A7 Pro and that's even with this thing
having some efficiency issues where we
should have expected more performance
but it's still so far ahead especially
if you look at speedometer 2.1 web
browsing performance it is just killing
Android now for reason number eight yes
the GPU performance is not better the
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 beats out the A7 Pro
which shows that Apple's struggling a
little bit with the GPU raw performance
but however they added metal FX
upscaling and games are actually already
supporting it unlike like the Android
games and apps that still have yet to
support it properly this actually makes
the quality look better on the iPhone
than on Android just so far ahead even
with low settings with metal effects it
clearly looks better at higher FPS as
well and this basically allows the 15
Pro to play AAA games like the upcoming
four games that Apple announced like
Assassin's Creed Resident Evil Village
and death stranding while Android phones
simply can't play AAA game ports for
number nine we have the excellent low
light performance on the 5x lens and
that's because Apple's using a unique
tetr prism design compared to a
traditional Periscope which actually
limits the size of the sensor so this
thing has a big sensor and very fast
f2.8 aperture which lets in a ton of
light for example the s23 ultra 10x lens
has an F 4.9 aperture which is pretty
dark in terms of the amount of light
coming into the sensor and on top of
that it has incredible 3D stabilization
with over 10,000 micro adjustments per
second so just look at this video
comparison of the 15 Pro Max's 5x camera
compared to the 10x on the s23 ultra it
is a massive massive difference and even
looking just at photo quality some of
the 10 X photos shots on the 5x camera
look comparable to the s23 ultra's 10x
camera but in low light Apple's 5x lens
wins by far now for number 10 the
battery life got even better with the 15
Pro Max even though Apple didn't mention
any battery life gains we've seen that
across multiple battery life tests with
the 15 Pro Max getting even better and
basically destroying every single
Android mainstream flagship phone with
the best battery life of all now for
number 11 we have something really
really cool and unique where apple is
allowing you to record prores 4K 60
video to an external SSD by simply
plugging it in to the USBC port and even
better than that they're actually
allowing log video recording which some
people have posted on X the quality of
the log and it looks absolutely insane
almost like a real film camera
absolutely killer dynamic range and
Android has none of that they have none
of those features so iPhone definitely
wins for video recording for number 12
we have the titanium frame which is very
high quality and very unique because
it's much more expensive than aluminum
and all the Android phones basically all
of them are using aluminum frames now
Zach from Jerry rig everything was
shocked that this is actually grade five
aluminum and not grade one as he
expected he said that one bar of grade
two costs
$170 while at the same time a bar of
aluminum is only 10 bucks and grade five
titanium is even more expensive he
showed off a little thin sheet of grade
five showing that it was insanely
expensive so Apple did a good job with
this grade five Titanium because it is
definitely more resistant to scuffs and
dents than aluminum now for reason
number 13 we have portrait photos that
can actually be taken without using
portrait mode you just take the photo
and then go into the edit menu and you
can add portrait mode and even change
the focal point which is absolutely
mindblowing now some Androids can
actually do this enabling and disabling
it but they have no depth data
information at all so the quality
actually turns out noticeably worse than
using portrait mode especially portraits
on the iPhone 15 series just look at
this example right here where you can
look along the stretch of the wall and
you can see the amount of blur slowly
increases as it gets further away
Android phones simply can't do this they
just have a whole block of the same
depth blur behind the subject now for
number 14 we have safety with apple
being able to connect to satellites
saving people's lives already and now
they've just added roadside assistance
for when you're stuck in your car it
broke down you don't know what to do you
can now use the satellites for that plus
of course they have other safety
features like fall detection crash
detection Androids don't have any of
that this is definitely the best phone
for safety and for number 15 we have a
really cool new feature for the iPhones
which is contact posters now when you
call somebody they're going to see your
contact poster like I've customized and
made mine right here which is a really
unique and cool feature which Androids
simply don't have you have like the
little icon the phone number the name
whatever this really makes the Iphone
15s unique especially with this new app
that I'm using contact poster Pro which
lets you fully customize your contact
poster with an image with really cool
backgrounds where it automatically Cuts
you out this is definitely a cool app so
anybody using iPhones you should
definitely check it out on the App Store
so there you guys go those were 15
reasons why the iPhone 15 Pro Max
destroys Android so let me know what you
thought down in the comment section
below subscribe above check out those
cases and accessories from J Sox check
out one of those two videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next
video